seit ausbruch des krieges in syrien 2011
leben mehr als 3,6 millionen flüchtlinge
in der türkei
viele wollen weiter nach europa um das
zu verhindern schloss die eu 2016 mit
der türkei einen pakt die türkei
verhindert illegale migration richtung
griechenland und nimmt auch geflüchtete
zurück dafür erhält sie sechs milliarden
euro 5,6 milliarden davon wurden laut eu
bereits bezahlt derzeit verschärft sich
das problem in der ägäis wieder in den
flüchtlingslagern auf den griechischen
inseln sind inzwischen etwa 24.000
geflüchtet registriert die lager völlig
überfüllt und laut dem
flüchtlingshilfswerk der un kamen allein
im august mehr als 8000 menschen aus der
türkei nach griechenland fast dreimal
mehr als im august 2008 10
ob die türkischen grenzkontrolle das
nicht verhindern können oder wollen sei
dahingestellt offiziell hält sich die
türkei an das abkommen
doch präsident erdogan hat ja auch damit
gedroht die grenzen zur eu für syrische
flüchtlinge zu öffnen
die betroffenen griechischen inseln in
der ägäis stellt der neue anstieg der
ankommenden flüchtlingsboote jedenfalls
vor erhebliche probleme
die lager sind überfüllt die behörden
kommen mit der registrierung nicht
hinterher
annette hilsenbeck berichtet es war ein
verzweifelter akt der neuen griechischen
regierung letzte woche siedelte sie rund
1400 menschen um machte sie aus dem
lager moria auf der insel lesbos zum
festland vor allem familien und
unbegleitete minderjährige trotzdem die
lage im camp hat sich kaum entspannt
diesmal erreichte lesbos mit seiner
familie vor wenigen tagen in moria haben
sie bisher zwei decken gekriegt nicht
viel mehr
sie hausen außerhalb des eigentlichen
camps in einem zeltlager es ist beengt
wir leben hier mit vier familien in
diesem wort insgesamt sind wir 16
personen
wir haben gefahren auf uns genommen
wussten dass wir ertrinken können das
haben wir getan damit unsere kinder eine
bessere zukunft haben
etwa 10.000 menschen sind es auch jetzt
noch in moria dreimal so viel wie
ursprünglich hier untergebracht werden
sollten
viele sind kinder und unbegleitete
jugendliche unter ein drittel der
bewohner ist unter 17 jahre alt täglich
kommen neue menschen ansuchen platz
zwischen denen die schon warten ob sie
asyl bekommen oder nicht bisher monate
oder gar jahrelang dieses system kann so
viele menschen nicht aushalten
generell muss das asylverfahren
beschleunigt werden damit der für mehr
menschen schneller und faire
abgeschlossen werden kann
griechenland will jetzt neue
sachbearbeiter einstellen das
asylverfahren verkürzen und sieht vor
allem den nachbarn in der pflicht den
türkei vertrag zu erfüllen wir fordern
von der türkei dass sie ernsthaft dafür
sorgt dass schlepper netzwerke
zerschlagen werden und dass sie nicht
zulässt dass erneut diese etablierten
flüchtlings routen entstehen das ist
einfacher geworden ist aus der türkei zu
fliegen berichtet ahmed er sei zuvor
sieben mal verhaftet worden sagt er
jetzt beim achten mal hat es keine
probleme gegeben
vor allem dafür dieses mal haben die
türkischen polizisten zugeschaut
wir haben uns einfach gehen lassen die
türkei ist nah wie viele migranten sich
auf den weg über das meer nach lesbos
machen hängt auch von der türkischen
regierung ab sagen blicken wir auf die
türkische perspektive jörg brase in
istanbul
präsident erdogan hatte jungs gedroht
die grenzen zu öffnen sollte die türkei
nicht mehr finanzielle unterstützung
bekommen ist denkbar dass er das
flüchtlings abkommen ganz aufkündigt
also ich glaube nicht dass er es ganz
aufkündigen will aber sieht so aus dass
man zumindest nach verhandeln möchte die
türkei profitiert ja auch von diesem
abkommen haben es gehört sechs
milliarden euro will die eu zahlen
ankara kritisiert nun dass dieses geld
nicht vollständig überwiesen wurde
bislang und man möchte wohl auch dass
die eu selbst mehr flüchtlinge aufnimmt
denn der druck auf die türkische grenze
von syrischer seite ist in den
vergangenen wochen enorm gestiegen
zehntausende sind vor den kämpfen in
idleb richtung türkei geflohen und
präsident erdogan hat gesagt mehr als
diese 3,6 millionen syrer die sich
zurzeit im land befinden könne das land
nicht verkraften
man sei schließlich nicht das
aufnahmelager europas gesehen steht
erfahren denn da selbst unter druck
innenpolitisch steht der unter enormen
druck denn die stimmung in der
bevölkerung hat sich in den vergangenen
monaten noch drastisch gewandelt eine
mehrheit sieht nun in den syrern hier im
lande eine bedrohung eine konkurrenz um
jobs und auch um wohnungen die es hat
auch schon erste angriffe gegeben auf
syrische geschäfte und diese stimmung
macht die regierungspartei akp
mitverantwortlich auch für die
wahlniederlage bei der
oberbürgermeisterwahl hier in istanbul
man will also jetzt härte zeigen auch
gegen die syrischen flüchtlinge soll
erste abschiebung gegeben haben oder
freiwillige rückkehr aufgrund von
massivem druck die türkei hat
mittlerweile in der tat ein eigenes
flüchtlingsproblem eine eigene
flüchtlingskrise steht unter großem
druck und den gibt es jetzt auch an die
europäer weiter dankeschön resta nase